yeah and the guys you know you said ugly  guys aren't but the thing is ugly guys  just aren't getting anything at all  those are the people you're even  acknowledging the people that you're  even talking to there's a lot of guys  that are just at home all day that they  just like do whatever they're doing that  that you don't even see so so it's in  your circle of guys that you're like oh  this guy's ugly but it's even people but  then that's why one in three are what do  you say one in three are like virgins or  something like that but someone might  find them attractive it's because  they're ugly to someone no no and on top  of that maybe you're right you said that  they're sitting at home that's probably  why they're not they're not [ __ ]  because no one can see them they're not  visible to the world